vielen dank und bambis alexander gauland
der fraktions und parteivorsitzende der
afg helgoland 171 tage haben wir jetzt
alle warten müssen
sie sind ja hier neu in den bundestag
mit ihrer fraktion eingezogen auch sie
haben warten müssen wären einzig
eigentlich zwischendurch lieber gewesen
das ganze wäre gescheitert uns hätte
neuwahlen gegeben
ich weiß nicht ob neuwahlen ein sehr
viel anderes ergebnis gebracht hätten
deswegen kann man nicht sagen das eine
oder das andere wäre besser gewesen
diese regierung ist falsch die politik
ist falsch aber ich bin ich sicher dass
neuwahlen zu einem anderen und für uns
besseren ergebnis geführt hätten
sie haben ja am wahlabend gesagt wir
werden sie jagen wenn man jetzt mal
zusammen zählt die aktivitäten der fdp
im deutschen bundestag dann ist man bei
den anträgen ganz weit hinten nur bei
den aktuellen stunden beantragen da sind
sie weit vorne
das ist noch ein erweiterungs
problematik oder woran liegt das heute
nicht viel mit einer weitaus
problematischer tun da war keiner
regierung haben kann man eine regierung
auch nicht im symbolischen sinne jagen
das gibt ja gab ja bis jetzt überhaupt
keine politik das heißt das ganze wird
sich jetzt erst einrenken in dem die
regierung vorschläge macht die wir dann
heftig zu kritisieren haben
das ganze war also quasi vorgeplänkel
wir haben auch so ähnlich empfunden klar
kann ein parlament eigentlich erst
richtig funktionieren wie die regierung
da ist das wird ja dann ab heute
nachmittag der fall sein
sie haben ja noch nicht alle funktionen
besitzt bekommen die sie eigentlich
besitzen dürfen zum beispiel den
parlamentsvize wann wird das der fall
sein
wir haben ja einen vorschlag gemacht die
anderen wollen unseren parlaments
vizepräsident nicht wir sehen uns nicht
in der lage jemanden anders
vorzuschlagen denn das was herr glaser
über den islam gesagt hat dass vertreten
wir alle ich wusste also niemanden den
ich vorschlagen könnte der eine andere
meinung hat sie sind da ja nicht
die einzigen denen das so gegangen ist
die grünen haben von 10 83 94 gar keinen
vize präsidentin gestellt und dennoch
ist das für eine fraktion im deutschen
bundestag natürlich eine schwächung
dieses wichtige amt nicht zu bekleiden
meinen sie nicht dass wenn sie von
jährige abgeordnete suchen dass sie den
einen oder anderen vielleicht auch
jüngeren finden der bei dieser frage
dann doch eine andere meinung hat das
hat nichts mit jung und nicht jung zu
tun sondern das hat damit zu tun dass
wir zum islam die meinung haben die herr
glaser ausgedrückt hat und diese meinung
haben auch jüngere in unserer fraktion
da wir in der fraktion dass diskutiert
haben von daher ist das gern aus mit
denen sie mehr davor schlagen wenn sie
auf das neue kabinett gucken wer
interessiert sie da am meisten horst
seehofer der bereits gesagt hat er will
stärker durchgreifen bei den ausländern
bei den zuwanderern pardon ich glaube
dass horst seehofer das macht also die
ganze zeit gemacht hat nämlich eine
harte politik ins schaufenster stellen
aber nichts machen die csu kämpft um die
absolute mehrheit in bayern das ist für
sie das entscheidende die bundesrepublik
ist gar nicht das entscheidende
und wir wissen ja dass obergrenze nichts
geworden ist das aus seehofers
ankündigung denn dass das unrecht zu
beenden
nichts geworden ist es wird auch aus
einem heimat ministerium nichts in
puncto abschiebungen alexander gauland
vielen dank dass sie da waren ja meine
damen und herren und jetzt geht es
weiter mit meinen kollegen erhard
schäfer